maryland governor larry hogan says it's
vital the fda approves all the
coronavirus vaccines used in the u.s the
republican is also pressing the biden
administration to immediately offer
booster shots to seniors and other
vulnerable people hogan a cancer
survivor says he has already received a
third vaccine shot he joins us now from
annapolis maryland governor good morning
thanks for being with us
good morning with fda approval of pfizer
the president is urging local leaders
state leaders to impose stricter
vaccination requirements what's the plan
for your state
well the great news in our state is that
we're one of the most vaccinated states
in the country and we've already
vaccinated more than 80 percent of the
adult population
nearly 95 percent of our vulnerable
population 65 and over because we took a
lot of steps early on uh but this is a
big step
for the approval of pfizer uh it really
has been the number one issue for people
that are being reluctant uh because it
didn't have the approval and now that
takes that argument away uh and we're
we're looking forward to trying to
finish up those last uh you know less
than 20 that we have remaining we also
have been pushing to make sure that we
can reach those uh younger kids as we
head back to school we want to get we
don't want to skip any steps but it's
it's critical that they get to work and
approving one vaccine is great but uh be
great to see if they can get final
approval on the other two as well yeah
as we mentioned you've already received
a booster shot a third shot
and the fda could authorize them for uh
for all adults in the fall how are you
going to ensure that the people who need
them
the third shot will get it
well it's critically important that they
they do and right now uh they already
authorized it for immune compromised
folks uh and uh yes you mentioned i'm a
cancer i had a cancer of the immune
system so my oncologist and our our
doctors recommended it but we we have
found we're doing antibody studies uh in
uh in all of our nursing homes and
finding that we're seeing a little bit
of loss of efficacy after five to six
months so some of our vulnerable folks i
know that they're working on this at the
federal level
but we think they need to speed that
process up we can't wait till later in
the fall we can't wait eight months and
so we have a call with the white house
later this morning and then i'll be
meeting with a number of other governors
with jeff zions the white house
coronavirus coordinator tomorrow uh and
we're hoping that we can make some
progress both on the other approvals on
the boosters and on uh you know the
approval for younger kids well governor
hogan first congratulations to you and
your state with those numbers those are
great i see your earpieces giving you a
little bit of a problem i know they're
they can't be extremely sorry i'm not
sure what the problem is but i i'll just
stand here with my finger in my ear and
talk to you no you were rolling with it
we appreciate that over the weekend
president trump former president trump
was booed by some of his supporters when
he recommended that they get the vaccine
i'm curious if that surprised you when
you saw that and why do you think there
is still so much skepticism about this
vaccine that people are willing to
ignore the science first did it surprise
you he was booed
it didn't really surprise me because you
know we've seen a lot of this
kind of anger and frustration there's a
lot of misinformation out there but
these were his own supporters i thought
but these were his own supporters yeah
well there's been a lot of
miscommunication for 18 months now and
uh for at least eight months with
respect to the vaccine and uh the
disinformation campaign is very
prevalent on social media a lot of
people believe very strongly in things
that just aren't true
and so it was good that the president
said that he got the vaccine but he
didn't really push the message as
strongly as i would have liked to have
seen and it really didn't surprise me
that some of the people reacted that way
hey governor hogan i'm hoping to switch
to afghanistan here because as we're
watching the scenes in kabul we know
there are tens of thousands of afghan
refugees they're going to be exiting
that country many of them coming to the
united states you have said you are
ready and willing in the state of
maryland to accept those refugees what
are you hearing from the biden
administration in terms of when they
could arrive and what kind of screening
is involved
well we've had some arrive over the past
couple of weeks a fairly limited number
as they were starting to do some of the
evacuations look these are these are our
allies that work side by side with us in
some cases for 20 years and we made a
commitment to them we've got to get all
of our americans out of there and our
allies as well i know that they're
working hard on it there's been a lack
of communication frankly i know that
1300 of them i think landed at dulles
airport
just over the line from us yesterday
they're
being processed and then we'll get
information about when when they get
relocated to various states i think i
was the first governor in the country to
say we got to stand by our allies we're
willing to take more we we currently
have
more uh of these siv special immigrant
visas that
we're the fourth
most in the country uh and our number
one uh segment of that is is folks from
afghanistan uh we want to continue to
try to help them relocate because we owe
it to them we made a commitment we can't
let them down i mean what does it say uh
you know how does that what kind of
messages send to our other allies around
the world if we don't
if our word is no good governor you
called the withdrawal an unmitigated
disaster what should we have done
differently
well you know i think just about
everything i think it was a mistake from
the the decision making from the
intelligence from
you know the execution and from the
communication standpoint the white house
seems to be you know trying to grapple
with it but it's it's been really done
about the opposite of any way you
probably should do it first of all we
shouldn't have given up bagram air force
base we shouldn't have telegraphed
exactly what we were doing to the
taliban we shouldn't have made an
agreement with them uh that that allowed
for a lot of this to happen and we
should make sure we get our people out
of there before we pull our all of our
troops um it's really pretty basic i'm
not a military strategy expert but uh it
seems like that's what some of the
advice was from the military leaders and
i think we just uh we just bungled it
from the start all right can we go back
to the do we have time can we go back to
covert for just a second because you're
one of the governors who appears to have
have a handle on this let's go down to
florida where they're they're fighting
against mass mandates there's still a
lot of talk about disinformation there
what do you say to your fellow governors
some in your own party
who are who are against the mass
mandates
well i mean not only are they against it
but they're mandating against it so you
know if they're the republican governors
who are saying they're all about freedom
and yet they're uh taking away the
freedom of local school systems and in
some cases businesses to make those
decisions for themselves you know we've
tried to find the right balance we've
been encouraging mass usage we left it
up to the duly elected school boards in
our state
that's that's who has the power to make
those decisions about two-thirds of our
school systems decided voted to wear
mass others decided not to but to
mandate that they have to or mandate
that they cannot just doesn't make sense
to me i think you know it's a it's a
basic conservative republican principle
to let local decision makers make
decisions yeah that is true governor
hogan thank you very much for joining us
we appreciate it